welcome back to new rockstars the first
episode of loki has unleashed multiple
loki variants upon the multiverse with
one in particular looking pretty
devilish but which loki is the most
evil or should we say the loki is loki
this is rogue theory the show where we
pitch the wildest theories for the stuff
we love i'm eric boss going rogue with
me today
is mt hey everybody it's me mt here
to get rogue get rogue
also with us is jessica clements uh
wanna rogue all night oh yeah
i don't know i tried to change up the
song
and also this is friend and twitch
streamer angelica trey
hey it's good to be back and the only
song i can think of
is i did it all for the theory the what
the theory yeah i don't like that that
popped into my head honestly and it's
it's
gonna stay there and it's awesome uh
well let's dive into loki there's so
much to talk about guys
episode one's final scene revealed this
mystery loki
variant who has been killing minutemen
and hunters and stealing their reset
charges
this hooded figure torches u-92 and the
others in an oil field
and we might have a pretty good idea of
who this hooded figure is exactly based
off of all the theorizing we've been
doing the past year
but whoever this is is this truly the
evilest loki
the ultimate big bad of the series or
really a misdirect that we're meant to
think is a big bad
and then someone else in the shadows is
truly the most evil loki
so which loki do you think could be an
even
worse threat throughout this series
this is a good question i mean we
obviously have you know this mysterious
character that richard e grant is
playing that they won't tell us who it
is
um even to this day and i don't think
he's even been
out on the the interviews in in no no
not at all
so you know that makes sense because
people would be asking him who are you
playing
so like i think that richard e grant is
playing um some type of variant or of
loki
um what like whether or not it's an
older version of loki
a more experienced version um i think i
i we don't know yet but i think that he
is actually playing
um this like more classic um sinister
mischievous loki that you know we've
seen throughout the comics like
in the beginning of the comics anyway um
when we are introduced to loki in the
comics
he's more like you know i want to just
do evil things and like
rule the world and like you were the
universe and all that stuff like that's
exactly how he talks we hang out
sometimes
um sorry i don't know why we did all
that but
it's the adhd it's it's like a picture
book for children i need
that sound so i i'm like oh i i know
what you're saying no i'm
in it you're experiencing what a real
loki will sound like i don't know what
i'm saying but you know it's like that
all the time empty just make that your
default setting
yes this is what the ladies like when i
talk to them like this on first dates
not just they don't get creeped out at
all
not just the ladies oh sorry i'm done
now
you sound like a wrestler or something
it's like a wrestler persona
he's like a really creepy wrestler yeah
and then i keep
i keep expecting you to just go i want
to rock like
in that voice suddenly yeah
you sound like roxo the clown
i gotta land this uh northwest orient
305 flight
uh back to the topic here uh because
i do think richard e grant is someone
behind the scenes here but for the
moment let's also talk about this hooded
figure we've theorized that this is
going to be
uh a female variant of loki basically
absolutely we saw
fluid on his rap sheet there in terms of
what his sex was
so i think this could be sophia
dumartino's character
but do we think lady loki is ultimately
going to be a true villain on this show
i definitely think it's lady loki the
moment i saw it i was like that is
feminine
energy and if i'm wrong i'm wrong but
i saw and i was like that's definitely
lady loki so i
think that it's gonna be one of those
cases where they get more acquainted
with lady loki you know
our tva loki is going to be
chasing or chasing her getting more
backstory in that sense
um and then it's gonna be there's gonna
be
fake outs i think so there's gonna be
like the older loki
and he's gonna seem really bad and then
i'm thinking also it'd be a really cool
spin if they had kid loki
and kid loki was actually like the worst
of them
but i think at the end of the day it's
gonna be tva is the bad guy yeah
no and yeah i think one idea mt pitched
me
i'm getting out you here is this idea
that maybe moebius could be some
uh mobius is one hundred percent a
low-key i'm getting 100
yeah okay i'm sorry that that's just
what i say when i'm really confident
okay okay
you're confident though wow i'm very
confident
that mobius is a loki just because of
the way he talks to loki
and like you know he's just like oh uh i
am smart i know you are
and like um just like the way that he
talks to him he's like
i know you because i am you it's in a
sort of way and so like i'm just like
you know what
you're on loki watch to me because i
feel like you're like
maybe like the maybe the oldest loki
loki prime i don't know
but something is go or maybe a loki from
after this
the series is over and he's like you
know what i'm gonna take down the tva
because you know this lady loki's right
we should take it on the tva but we got
to do it from within
um but yeah mobius he's giving me low
keyboards i don't know but that's just
i like that thank you but like i just
expect them all to have dark hair
yeah i know right is he bleaching his
hair
you're not allowed to bleach your hands
okay impossible yeah
okay is he gonna like do a wig reveal
and he's gonna have dark slicked back
hair underneath like how's that gonna
work
i mean like with variants anything can
happen you could literally
look like anything so like i feel like
blond hair is on the table at that point
yeah speaking of hair changes jess we
gotta
hear from you here this is the just
barrier speaking of
i like that uh segway i
ultimately i think i agree with both of
you i think that the big bad will be the
tva
because they're um and slightly i guess
kind of what
um um mt said i think that i don't think
mobius
is loki i think moby is just a cog with
the tva and like the timekeepers
in a situation i think they're bad
because ultimately
it was the pushing of that interview
between loki and him was more so he even
said that like
you're made to make good people good
and you are trying to be a hero that
makes zero sense
so i think the fact of it is they're
trying to push him more into the
narrative of being evil
and not dying a hero so i do think the
tva is up to no good
i do think the person in the cloak is
definitely lady loki
but if there was any regards to it not
being her i think it could be
older loki but not in the sense of like
elder loki like
it could be richard e grant i think it
would be
more of like so they did talk about at
the beginning how there was a
multiversal war
so what if that's a loki from another
multiverse i guess that
lost in the multiversal war and can just
jump timelines
in order to like redeem themselves as
the like this was my timeline
it lost but it didn't deserve to lose
because it's still loki so it's like
still mischievous still bad
so i think that loki could be just like
terrorizing everything because it needs
to like do something to redeem itself
for a losing of them
yeah jess i think that's a great idea
like that was something i was thinking
about as well that like when they talk
about this
old past multiversal war that that was
some other previous time period and this
ancient loki like the oldest loki could
have been from that older time period
uh and now maybe he rose up the ranks to
become you know
he who remains or something the elder of
the tv yeah
yeah he created these time keepers
created this whole propaganda
of of this story timeline to one
uh and then now this repeat universal
cycle loki
is screwing it all up so it is in a way
tva is a big bad but it's still loki
versus loki in that way that
the the variant they are chasing while
in this uh
particular short-term goal is lady loki
but at the end of the day they are also
hunting
an older variant of loki
did they confirm that the time war was
old and she did say long ago they said
yeah yeah the time
miss time what if miss minutes yes
please get her name right because that's
my wife okay why are you into this clock
i'm just messing around no he's telling
the truth
i know you're not honestly the clock got
me a little
exactly thank you
i started trying to do the accent like
while she was talking i was like oh my
god this voice actor is so so
freaking what's up
[Laughter]
so so here i i know this isn't part of
the
the original question but i was thinking
that the
time wars were actually the the
multiverse of madness oh sure
events because time works a little
differently and so
if time works a little differently they
then go back they go back through the
pass they go back through the
you know they go into the future and
they try to maintain any timeline that
keeps the tva
alive and they're setting themselves up
as this
ultimate envelope that is a great idea
good idea i really need it
to be secret wars because uh when i
first started on rogue theory that's all
i would bring up yeah
i have a feeling so we needed to loop
back and just confirm your original
i just need yeah
a secret wars thing because like we see
in the in the uh
presentation that the timelines uh come
together
in like a little like what do you call
it um thunderbolts come out when the the
title is called the branch
those are the incursions so like yo i'm
telling you we get in the secret wars
eventually
get ready for sure for sure secret wars
is coming uh no doubt no doubt
but i do think uh it is possible that
like
a multiverse of madness is kind of a
destined cyclical event the way ragnarok
is
a destiny cyclical event uh and while i
think what we saw in the past was a past
multiverse of
madness this will be uh multiverse of
madness two is what we're about to run
into
or infinite n plus one you know uh
because there's there it always happens
over and over again i think time is a
flat circle
i think mcconaughey was speaking truth
time time is a flat circle because
yeah they're monitoring time and time
works differently in the tva
so anything that happened in the future
could technically be thought of as
happening in the past for them and
anything that's happening in the past
could just feel like the present because
they can just go back to whatever time
these are the conversations i love i'm
gonna need a piece of paper
you know speaking of i hate it this is
where my sci-fi like deep knowledge
really comes in handy
i'm like time travelers you know
speaking of a flat circle uh have you
guys heard of my wife uh miss minutes
she's great
[Music]
i
the right way just a full a full one
that goes three
okay i don't like
she is
[Laughter]
[Music]
uh jess a point i like this idea of the
multiverse
war in this uh this villain coming from
the past
and that's uh who will be the evilest
loki
on this show uh i think you're on to
something jess
so you're you're winning if the show
ended right
now you would have won it unfortunately
we got to keep going there's more to
talk about
uh so first we want to remind you all
that over
at newrockstarsmerch.com we've unveiled
the fourth shirt design and our limited
edition latest obsession series loki out
of time
it's such a cool shirt uh mine's coming
soon hopefully because i can't just wear
this shirt it's starting to smell like
tony stark after four time heists
but this other shirt design looks cool
if you get it you'll get the ability to
leave a message on our inside marvel
loki after show with either a shout out
your own rogue theory whatever you want
to write it'll be there at the bottom of
the screen
but then as mt catelya we got a full
lineup of loki inspired merch including
an augmented reality shirt
some miss minute stickers some tva
buttons all kinds of cool stuff
find it over at newrockstarsmerge.com
and we want to thank away travel for
sponsoring this episode of rogue theory
away travel creates thoughtful products
for every traveler and every kind of
trip
a lot of folks are going to be traveling
this summer for the first time in a
while i know i'm excited to get out
there
no matter what your destination or style
away suitcases
bags and accessories all come in a
variety of colors and sizes and
materials to suit
your needs and inspire your future
travels away products are designed to
last a lifetime if any part of your
suitcase breaks away standout customer
service team will arrange to have it
fixed or replaced
there's a 100 day trial on everything
away makes take it out on the road and
put it to the test
if you decide it's not for you you can
return any non-personalized item for a
full refund during that period away
offers free shipping and returns on any
order within the contiguous united
states uk
europe and canada start your 100 day
trial
and shop the entire away lineup of
travel essentials including their
best-selling suitcases at away travel
dot com
rogue that's away travel dot com rogue
we also want to thank credit karma money
for sponsoring this episode credit karma
has always been there to help you make
better financial decisions and now they
want to help even more
with a credit karma money spend account
you can be rewarded for good money
habits
credit karma money is a brand new
checking account where you can win cash
reimbursements for making purchases when
you use your credit karma money debit
card you can win
daily instant karma purchase
reimbursements on items up to five
thousand dollars just pay with your
debit card and if you win
you will be notified on the spot and
your instant karma cash will be added
back to your spend account open your
fdic insured spend account for
free there's no minimum balance
requirements and free withdrawals from
over
50 000 atms and when you make a purchase
between june 8th and june 30th
you'll be automatically entered to win
one
million dollars what so
one million what right now visit
creditkarma.com
win money to open your free account and
start winning
instant karma go to creditkarma.com
money just sign up for free and start
winning insta karma that's
creditkarma.com
win money instant karma is sponsored by
credit karma no purchase necessary
exclusions and term supplies see rules
banking services provided by mvb
bank inc member fdic maximum balance and
transfer limits apply we also want to
thank
bluechu for sponsoring this episode our
friends at bluechu
have a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in two of all form
and at a fraction of the cost
blue chew is an online prescription
service so no doctor's office or
pharmacy trips it ships right to your
door in a discreet package
you sign up at bluechew.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you are approved
you receive your prescription within
days their licensed medical providers
work with you to find the right
ingredient and strength
and if you hate swallowing pills good
news blue chew is chewable just like it
says in the name
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to perform
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information
and we've got a special deal for our
audience try bluetooth free when you use
our promo code rogue at checkout just
pay the five dollars in shipping
that's bluechew.com promo code rogue to
receive your first month free and we
thank bluetooth for sponsoring this
episode
all right back to loki so uh one of the
best moments from loki episode one is
when it is revealed that loki was
actually
db cooper the mystery hijacker of
northwest orient flight
back in 1971 uh someone who was never
found
i just love this idea that loki was
behind it it was just
loki's the answer to it uh and mt uh
recently interviewed loki creator
michael waldron
who revealed that his writers had a
whole board of other historical
mysteries that loki could have been
behind
so i want to know from you guys what
other urban myth do you think loki could
be responsible for beyond didi cooper
hmm i think it'd be really fun
like super fun because like we know from
thor ragnarok
that loki likes to turn thor into uh
different animals and such
so i think it'd be great if like he
turned thor into bigfoot and like people
were like oh my god
that's bigfoot i'm just trying to get
home man i don't know where i am
like i'm just i would love to see that
just like
him walking and then often it clips and
then you realize that he's bigfoot
that would be such a good reveal that
seems like something like he would do
you know the mandela effect what if loki
messed around with every mandela effect
is just something loki did that would be
hilarious
yeah yeah cause because all of the urban
myths i'm thinking of right now like the
mysteries are
so dark but but like in terms of mandela
effect stuff
you know you have shots in the loki
series of loki going um
i think berenstein should have an a in
it or something like that or
i think he should say you should take
out the luke and just say i
am your father you know something like
that yeah i think that would be really
funny
i feel like that goes no i am yeah
exactly
like the the yeah because the mandela
effect is when people have
like large groups of people have a
certain memory
and it's you know like our our history
doesn't prove that at all and so it's
like this phenomenon that a ton of
people have and
people only can really explain it by
either false memory
or some sort of parallel reality what if
loki was
messing with that i like that idea um i
mean like and loki could potentially do
something like that
technically in this series because like
hey he's hopping around but b
there was a drawer full of reality
stones i don't know if anybody saw that
[ __ ]
so you could use one of those red rocks
to
make something like that like a mandela
effect so that'd be cool
i think it would be fun if he was king
arthur
and merlin so with there's those tall
tales that merlin and king arthur
actually worked together and they were
close people and like just work together
that's like a super big legend but it
would be funny if that legend was
actually
just that the people saw this one being
that they somehow over time turned into
two different people merlin
and king arthur and it was actually um
it was actually loki that's just doing
magic and it's also just
loki that took the sword out of the
stone but it was just probably like a
dagger
and they were like in overtime it was
just like yes our king
took a sword out of a stone but he
literally just put a dagger from his
like wrist and was like
just take it just take it i don't care
what it does and they were like oh
so i think it'd be fun if he was merlin
and king arthur or just one of the two
i love that idea and i love because i
think merlin
is technically part of the marvel lore
as well like merlin is a marvelous yeah
yeah marvin for sure and he's actually
associated with the tva
fun fun fact sort of wow in a way
yes he's had dealings with the tva i
going into the show is like
there's no way they're gonna go too dark
because the good thing about db cooper
is like there were no casualties there
like no one got hurt he just jumped down
the plane
we think db cooper's probably dead but
um but
like the uh ending scene
where you know this loki variant burns
people alive that was like out of game
of thrones that was dark
violent stuff so i'm like wondering like
could we
be loki involved with like the jack the
ripper
myth with the zodiac story with jfk
actually recently last week and jess i
think you were there for this
conversation where off-screen producer
brandon
pitched like a take of the jfk uh
assassination
oh i was i was okay yeah yes and i was
like oh that'd be
fun but it's not umbrella academy i
don't think yeah i know i know i know
the idea that a lot of people have is
that maybe like they're
like lee harvey oswald did fire but like
missed
and the secret service who was like
hungover from the night before
accidentally shot uh and they shot jfk
and that's why there's multiple angles
and it's super weird it was a huge
cover-up and that's why they can never
bring anything out
because really the the bullet that
struck and killed him
conspiracy theorists they might have
come from the bullet of
a secret service agent and it's still
the secret service to the day
to the state he's protecting the
president and we need them to protect
the president right so we don't want
them to be too involved in a scandal
i mean i think we can still we can still
get the goriness if he's like
actually the devil um because you know
when they pointed
adam was just like me and it was the
devil loki but it's obviously
is it me but it was the devil loki
um and it's obviously just like loki
with horns that people over time were
like yeah that's the devil he came here
and just killed a bunch of people for no
reason
so we could still get those like
flashbacks even though like um the loki
were seen and following is a loki that's
definitely just like
i don't believe in actually killing
people the ones in different timelines
probably do so it's like we'll probably
run into the devil loki that just
straight up
who is actually maybe king loki or
whatever but he's gonna be like
murdering people for no reason sure yeah
i think so
oh that i think that's really great but
i think what one of the coolest
um uh what do you call it one of the
coolest urban myths that uh
loki could actually be behind is a
little myth called
uh noob master 69 i mean i don't know if
you guys heard of it but oh
oh yeah he's no we know that's dc
pearson dc pearson is he's dcp
that's true well like that was a
commercial though that was a commercial
so it might not be but
he was in a winter soldier as aaron says
the same guy just working at the apple
store
also a gamer uh tech nerd right we
should ask kevin feige if the commercial
i mean we could just ask dc pearson i
think he's an authority on this
he was on i'm actually with us a word
yeah he did an epi he did an episode
with vaughn oh dang
all right i don't know who won that
episode i'm the winner did you
did you i won that episode i'm a
smart boy i did not finish it big baby
break i started it
and then i didn't finish it but i'm very
proud of it thank you it's okay
uh that's a good episode to win yeah
that's a good time you should oh
damn it i need to get you that hard
footage yeah
well uh of these different theories
i'm going to give the point to a trey
cause i think the mandela effect is
fascinating
and uh you know a fairly safe thing that
they could just say loki was somehow
behind
and i hope that's the case great
conversations there
guys we have time for one rogue
question let's do a shift in topic here
uh
to the lord of the rings because a group
of fans has started a petition to remove
any nudity or sex scenes from the
upcoming amazon
lord of the rings series i know i know
are you kidding me
put more in i say pack it in there
eight hours of softcore but um
eight hours amazon they can do whatever
they want
the boys is getting it's you know
getting some people it's true oh it's
getting it's oh it's gonna get crazy
it's gonna get real inappropriate
inappropriate that's true that's very
true but the question is what
sex or nudity scene do you wish was
removed from something
oh this question was gone it's gonna go
a different way all right
oh god there's so many i'm trying to
think of ones that made me like
obviously
like ones that aren't as problematic
but like just like i don't need to see
these two people having
um like there's probably a ton of times
in my when i was a kid
when i'm watching a movie with my
parents and then like it's just like a
sex scene i was like i don't want to be
here with my
dad and having a weird thing with this i
don't know it's really weird
you know what i think that's i think
that's part of growing up though i think
that's just part of life
you need a dream you got to have that
awkward experience with your parents at
least
it humbles you early it really does
i'm thinking watchmen but like i know
i'm thinking of like a literal one
oh yeah the watchman one i did not i'm
like no like the the two thousand
six or five oh the one said to leonard
cohen's hallelujah yeah
and then she hit the button and then the
owl [ __ ] stop stop
stop i fast forward that scene when i'm
watching it by myself
because i don't need it like i was like
i don't know
yeah we didn't need that that's a bit
excessive the song was
not a good song choice there why would
they i love this song
i don't need you to remember the way
snyder used it
but um not good in the watchman other
than watchmen
i did not need the sex scene and splice
i did not need him having splices
you guys haven't seen his flight adrian
brody having sex with his alien daughter
did not need that didn't want it
didn't need to see it i love adrian
brody
and when i saw that scene it made me not
like him
and it was not even like it was i
and i'm in hollywood so we know we're
like oh this was just a character it's
just a character but i'm like
i cannot take that out of my mind
and they and it was so long and they
were in like a shed
so the the sunlight hit his butt and i
was like don't
eat this i was like stop it it is
embedded in there
it like oh it makes me oh like
okay okay okay i'm done it's disgusting
that's my number one
and then watch the most descriptive i've
ever seen
a uh a nude scene the sunshine hitting
the butt
it's perfect cinematography yeah
honestly i could
i could see it now the just a graphic
replay in my head
any sex scene in a dirt in broad
daylight is enough for me to
not like it sun's out don't
take those buns out i think like the
most unnecessary one for me is probably
gonna be dr manhattan in
watchmen because i didn't need to see
the blue pina
i didn't need to see that blue blue dick
yeah but it wasn't
i loved
when he was having sex with her and she
was like it's like sucking a battery
i don't remember that part i just
remembered
uh wow i think we have sufficiently uh
disturbed
our audience and actually yeah not
apologize
one bit uh because you know what you're
getting into when you say this late in
the episode of rogue
i told you we're going to get rogues we
got rolls we skew into
but uh jess you're getting the point
there because
i think you all reminded us of that
adrian brody alien sex we don't need to
see it
we never needed to see it
um so jess you are the winner of this
episode of rogue theory
well done my friend uh
but all of us uh all of us have come up
with some great theories and i said
us because i'm proud of myself but i'm
proud of umt
i'm proud of you angelica i'm proud of
you too
we covered some great ground here and i
can't wait to dig more into loki as you
know this is on friday
we're doing this so that we can talk
about the most recent episode of loki
with you here on rogue theory
because that's let's be honest the thing
we're all gonna be theorizing the most
about these next
uh six weeks uh but i wanna thank all of
you for joining us including jessica
clements mt
angelica trey support all of them on
their social medias
uh and show them some love you can
support this channel by checking out one
of our many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com
you can follow us at new rockstars on
social media subscribe to new rockstars
we might be at 3 million now who knows
we're close we might be there
um well be sure to follow me at avos
vitalmind
and subscribe and we will see you next
week bye everybody
later guys love you guys bye
[Music]
you